now i remember i saw you tell a story
one time it's on it's on youtube
somewhere but you're talking about
a patient you were working on you kind
of alluded to this earlier
you know either pre-diabetic or diabetic
and
you're sitting there going you got to be
kidding me because the day before you
tried to save someone's life that was
you know a young kid
and that was sort of was that the first
time that you started thinking about
nutrition as a
you know and earlier you talked about
hey we do all the stuff at the end of
life it's all this preventation to
prevent someone from actually dying
but if we would have invested some of
that money up front taught these people
how to eat
we would have been better off is that
sort of where it came from or not at all
i mean i never made that connection at
that time
right so at that time it was just what
you described it was just the visceral
reaction of
i'm so angry at you how can you not take
care of yourself
how can you be sitting here so fat so
diabetic
you know over and over again you come in
here
to have these ulcers debrided and to
have these things amputated
and you know how the story is going to
go like just get it together so this was
i mean i didn't say those words but
that's how i'm feeling right
and so
that's that's just part of like the the
callousness that developed towards that
subset of patient
it wasn't until
probably 2009 um so i'm you know out of
medicine now
but i was becoming overweight and i was
pre-diabetic i wasn't diabetic i was
pre-diabetic
and i was you know that i was sort of
come full circle right that i was like
wait a minute
i do everything right i mean i'm
swimming four hours a day
i'm following that goddamn food pyramid
to the core
i don't need saturated fat i'm like you
know i
i carb load like a banshee like why am i
why is all this stuff happening to me
and so so then when i
you know went through my whole discovery
process of figuring that out
it was only then that i really thought
back and reflected upon
you know the horrible way i had treated
not just that patient particularly but
obviously many other patients like her
i remember her case specifically because
it was probably like the absolute
low point of my existence um
so it unfortunately it took me sort of
failing
on my own because at least then i could
say this isn't a willpower problem it's
not like you don't care
it's not like you're not trying you're
doing what you're told to do and you're
failing miserably so
either you're an outlier or maybe the
advice is incorrect
so you're eating what you're being told
to eat you're carb loading
and you're still getting fat even though
at this time you're swimming
we were just talking about it before the
podcast you're doing ultra long swims
dozens of miles worth of swimming which
by the way
in seal training in basic seal training
the longest you swim
is five and a half nautical miles which
is 6.2
statute miles which and that's with swim
fins on so you're out there in the end
you're out there in the open ocean
swimming 12 15
18 miles at a time and you're training
for that
working hard and you're quote unquote
eating right because you're
not eating saturated fat and yet you're
getting fat you're going to the doctor
you get blood tests and they say oh yeah
by the way you're pre-diabetic
and you just say to yourself what is
going on yeah and and truth be told i
was actually more pissed just from the
vanity standpoint at being fat
i mean you know i wish i could say for
those of you on the podcast echo is
nodding his head
enthusiastically to that i mean i i mean
i wish i could say like oh it didn't
bother me to be fat it did bother me to
be fat it really bothered me to be fat
right it bothered me
it bothered me a lot actually and so
much so that i actually wanted to get a
gastric bypass and so
i i would were you i was like
so right now i'm about 175 i was like
probably 205 to 210.
oh dang okay so once again after this
podcast you and i we're going to the
counseling sessions
so i went to i finally got my doctor to
get me a referral
to this guy named ken fujioka who's like
a
very prominent bariatric physician here
in san diego
so i finally go to see fujioka so i'm
sitting in the waiting room
and uh actually i think i told this
story on tim's podcast
i don't remember telling you you did
tell it but it is in it's in the book
it's in the history oh yeah yeah yeah i
think the story tells the titans yeah
but in the spirit of assuming nobody
listens to or reads multiple other
things
so i'm in the waiting room i'm finally
waiting to see
and the nurse comes out and before you
go back to the to the clinic room
like you have to get weighed that's just
part of the protocol right so
like they call my name so i walk up and
i get on the scale
and the nurse comes out and weighs me
and it's like you know whatever 210 and
she's like
congratulations i'm like what
she goes you're post surgery right and
i'm like
no i'm here to be evaluated for surgery
yeah
she like looks at me looks out at the
waiting room where everybody's 400
pounds
and like doesn't say a word but the look
in her eyes
is basically like what the hell is wrong
with you guys
you got serious it's your son um
but it seemed like a reasonable idea
well yeah
very reasonable very reasonable you
might want to check your reasonable
ideas with me
in the future because that is not a
reasonable idea
so you get done you don't do that
surgery obviously
but yeah he that guy had no patience for
me what clicked in your brain did you
just
all of a sudden say to yourself okay how
is this happening and then you
remembered your anp
class no and said this is the word
so i remember clear is day so uh
september 7th 2009
i did uh you i sort of did like one of
these long swims a year
you know you do a bunch of short ones a
bunch of training but always i had one
main event my main event this year
was i went back to catalina island and i
wanted to swim from now
la out to catalina i had previously gone
from catalina
to la and um
it was a tough swim i had a torn labrum
so
about six hours in you know it just
became unbearable pain
um and you don't usually have a
head current in the catalina channel so
the san pedro channel you know this
you're probably trained out there
the current's usually running from point
conception down or up so you usually
have a little bit of a cross current
very rare to get anything back or forth
and if
anything it's generally a little bit
towards the island
and when i had swum four years earlier
from catalina
to l.a it took 10 and a half hours but
that was only 18 months after i learned
how to swim
i was a much better swimmer in 2009
and i was going in the theoretically
faster direction so
a great example is expectations can kill
you
so i'm expecting this to be like a nine
hour swim
back and and really the only thing i'm
thinking about which is the worst thing
you think about in marathon swimming you
should never
ever ever think about how long this is
going to take because you just you're
just setting yourself up for misery
the only real question is could i break
nine hours you know i should be able to
break nine hours right
so to make a long story short i don't
even come close this is a
total disaster scenario the other you
you never want to look anywhere when
you're swimming except down
um it's very demoralizing when you're in
the middle
like if you're in the middle of the
channel you don't see land from the
water level
you just you just don't so that's to so
before you get in the water you tell the
crew
and every i've crew chief for a lot of
great swimmers i mean it's the
the crew asks the swimmer what do you
want what information do you want
so we're starting to swim at midnight at
point vicente i said
okay i want to know when there are
exactly 10 miles to go and exactly four
miles to go
what's that what's the total distance of
the swim well as the crow flies it's 21.
um and if so if you don't have a current
you're doing a 21 mile swim yeah if you
do have a current you're going to swim
more than that
so so that's why i said guys i want to
know when there's ten to go and
four to go why tend to go you're just a
little over halfway
i'd like to just know that at four to go
it's put your head down and swim for two
hours don't do anything you're there
so we start the swim at midnight this is
in september so
i forget what time the sun was rising
back then but i knew
that i would have 10 to go before the
sun came up
so in other words i knew that once the
light was up i was going to be
inside the 10 stretch and one of the
most amazing things about swimming in
the middle of the ocean i don't know if
you got to experience this during
training is in the pacific the
bioluminescence
is so strong and so on a clear night
which i was always lucky to have every
time i swam out
i've done a lot of the channel swims
every time i've been out there i've
always been blessed with these clear
nights
it's so dark because once you get out of
la's light
under the water so your hand is coming
down you are seeing the bioluminescence
flare off your hands
when you breathe you were seeing the
stars you can't tell the difference
it is so dark you cannot see the
difference between stars and
bioluminescence it's like being in this
amazing chamber
and so that's the that's the reward you
get for swimming at night which is
otherwise incredibly lonely
and then the first thing you notice is
the bioluminescence gets harder and
harder to see which means oh the sun's
going to be up in an hour
and the sun comes up now the sun's like
up there
i haven't heard anything and i'm like
those guys
they forgot to tell me i've got 10 to go
that's okay
probably down to six to go now and i'm
swimming i'm swimming i'm swimming it
must be like 10 o'clock in the i mean
i'm being facetious it's probably
like 8 30 in the morning and they're
like 10 to go
and i was like jesus what
and because at that point i had no clue
what the current was like
because a swimmer can't feel current
right swimmers can only feel relative
velocity not absolute velocity
so you know that coupled with the torn
labrum
coupled with like it ended up being over
14 hours of swimming
and there's a very long story because
your question was so simple but i
remember getting on the boat
i don't even remember my question your
question was about nutrition about
about like when i finally decided i was
over here in bioluminescenceville
okay so this is the day so so finish the
swim hours get back to the boat
and they've got like two burgers and two
cokes waiting for me
and i mean like i couldn't have eaten
those things quicker like the biggest
juiciest burgers you've ever seen like
the cokes like they
tasted so good right because you know
your mouth is so salty like you actually
really want something sweet
and my wife this you know my wife hates
when i tell this story because she
denies that she said it but she
completely said it
um i'm just sitting there like right i'm
remember this i have a picture
of the burger fatty i've got like a usa
towel wrapped around my waist
inhaling like i'm two fisting burgers
drinking my cokes
and she just looks at me and she goes
and again just in the sweetest
way possible she said you you should
probably work on being a little less
not thin wow
is that like the kindest way to just
tell somebody you're kind of getting a
little fat
wow post 14 hour swim
get some so that was the last time i had
a coke
i've never had a coke since um
and all i did frankly at the time was
just say like i'm just going to try and
experiment
because i was like look at that time i
still thought it was just calories and
calories out i thought it was really
just simple arithmetic and my view was
all right
i can't do anything more on the calories
outside
there's only 168 hours in a week i'm not
willing to exercise more than 28 of them
so calories out i don't get to change
that anymore
and frankly i didn't really want to
change the calories inside because i
hated being hungry every time i tried to
eat less i would just be so hungry i
didn't know what to do with myself
so i was like i'm gonna try a new
experiment what if it's the type of
calorie
that might matter sugar strikes me
as not great for you even though i can't
tell you
why i'm gonna stop having sugar
so that was my first experiment in
september of 09 and that
led to everything that's come since that
time which obviously ultimately led to
me coming back to medicine as well
yeah and that's where you're at now and
and by the way um listen to tim tim's
podcast what else should people listen
to to get all that nutritional
information this the rest of the story
i think it's tim's yeah i mean a couple
things with tim um
i did a podcast with chris kresser um
earlier this year talked about longevity
a little bit
i did one i did probably have a maybe oh
you know probably get more into
nutrition on there's an ihmc video i did
probably like three or four years ago
that one's like an hour long
and you go pretty detailed in it yep
okay yeah i've watched that one
yeah those are good those are good
and again if you had to kind of
tell people that aren't going to go
listen to those podcasts aren't going to
watch that
that video what would you tell them
you know what would you tell them to eat
overall
you know i i generally don't like
talking about nutrition because
uh don't worry i will answer this
question but i don't at least preface it
why i don't like it i don't like talking
about this stuff
um nutrition
is kind of a pseudoscience that
masquerades as a religion
for many people and so i
find it difficult to have a discussion
about biochemistry
when it's so cloaked in emotion religion
and dogma now that's not to say i don't
have a strong point of view i certainly
do
it's also an evolving point of view i
feel different today than i felt four or
five years ago
i feel different today than i felt two
years ago and also my life is one big
experiment
right so you know we were joking before
i came in here and i've got a glucose
meter buried within me at the moment
i've got like
all these heart rate variability things
like everything i'm doing
actually let me just check i
actually did an experiment before i came
here today i ate something
and i want to see how much it raised my
blood sugar
that's not bad what did you eat so i ate
this
product that i've been doing some
research on it's called
no k n o w like no
foods and i was introduced to this
product by one of my patients
who said hey peter i want you to kick
the tires on this a little bit
it's um it's it uses a sugar substitute
called allulose
and it tastes amazing and apparently
like it doesn't raise your blood sugar
at all
and i was like yeah i'm familiar with
allulose
for for those who might not know
allulose is a
[Music]
sugar that occurs in nature in very
small quantities
that looks exactly like this sugar
called fructose which is
fruit sugar the sweet component of sugar
with one small
exception but that one small exception
carries with it some very important
things
one it's not quite as sweet as fructose
it's about 70 percent as sweet
but by giving up that little bit of that
sweetness you get a whole bunch of stuff
in return first of all it's not
metabolized by the liver
which is the real problem of fructose 2
you barely absorb it
so 99 of it or more or less is excreted
by the kidneys
and three it actually seems to lower
blood glucose
so this company no foods
is putting this like making stuff out of
this
but stuff that is like carby like bread
and waffles and muffins and stuff
so anyway to make a long story short i'm
at this patient's house and he's
force-feeding me these things which is
really
my way of saying he's left the bag open
and i'm inhaling them
and he's like yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta like tell me if this stuff's legit
so to make a long story short he plugs
me into the guy who founded the company
and he has sent me a bunch of this stuff
to just play with
because he knows what i do and so that's
what i've been doing so today
i normally don't eat breakfast so i
worked out this morning
and then before i came here i had a big
piece of their toast
covered in almond butter and then two of
their huge waffles
covered with almond butter and bananas
like i made a big sandwich out of that
so the almond butter not gonna have a
huge glycemic response because it's got
so much fat and protein in it but the
bananas should skyrocket my blood sugar
not to mention the two freaking waffles
the size of my head and the piece of
toast so
interestingly so that was at nine
o'clock that i
ate those now i've been up since 3 30
but i didn't eat anything i worked out
from seven to eight
so admittedly there's a bit of a
glycogen debt so at nine o'clock
when i ingested my blood glucose was 65
and at its peak which was 11
18 a.m it was up to 90. and it's now
down to 83. what would real waffles have
done to you
i think they would have sent me to like
140.
three huge pieces of bread slash waffle
with the full banana
so anyway i've been doing these
experiments all week which is just a
great excuse to eat this stuff
and i'm actually surprised i'm kind of
blown away so
okay with all that said what's my advice
for what people should eat
in an ideal world everybody would have
this thing embedded in them like i do
this thing is called a dexcom g5 it's a
continuous glucose monitor
typically only used by people with type
1 diabetes um
we're now starting to see people with
type 2 diabetes wear them but
um i was really completely lucky one day
sitting on an airplane next to a dude
who happened to be into watches i'm into
watches we got talking about watches
i find out he's the ceo of the company
that makes this thing
the rest is history right i'm like
obsessed with this stuff
and so because the answer is this
right if you were a computer program i
would say jocko
eat whatever you want to eat such that
your average blood glucose
remains below 85 milligrams per
deciliter
and your standard deviation below 10
milligrams per deciliter
so translate that into english okay so
eat in
whatever way your genetics and
epigenetics permit you to
such that your glucose levels stay low
and the variability stays low and those
two things will ensure that your insulin
levels stay low
so what i'm trying to do is optimize for
something called the insulin auc
or area under the curve now we can't
measure that test clinically
the only way i could measure that is put
you in a hospital put a central line in
your neck
and excuse me sample your blood every 30
minutes over the course of a day
where you somehow act normally and every
day so then i'd have a time axis
y-axis the sorry the x-axis would be
time the y-axis would be
insulin level and we'd generate a curve
and we'd calculate the area under
that curve and we want that number to be
as low as possible
so we can't do that outside of the
research setting so then the next best
thing is
keep your average glucose as low as
possible and the variability so
you could have an average glucose of 100
with low variability
and that actually wouldn't produce that
much insulin or you could have a glucose
of 100 with high variability
same average glucose higher variability
is going to have higher insulin all
things equal
so just through empirical testing in
myself over the past
year and a half i've realized that an
average blood glucose and this thing
tells me every time i hit click like it
gives me my last 14 days
i just realized like for my average to
be below 85 and my standard deviation to
be below
10 is like super dialed in
so what you can eat to achieve that
varies tremendously by individual you
know there are some people who just
dispose of glucose remarkably so that
blood test we're going to do in you next
week
is going to be our best test at
measuring that
um and so so glucose disposal is
is mostly a function of the insulin
sensitivity of the muscle
because the muscle is where we dispose
of the majority of glucose
but it's more a little more complicated
than that right sleep impacts that
right so sleep deprivation makes
us more insulin resistant so this has
been experimentally demonstrated even
with
two weeks of sleep deprivation so
there's a it's a
small but very well controlled
experiment that was done at the
university of chicago
price six years ago they took a very
small number of subjects like i said
about eight subjects
and for two weeks let them only sleep
four hours a night
and they did a very invasive test called
a
glycemic insulin clamp at the beginning
and at the end of the experiment
and their insulin uh sensitivity their
glucose disposal deteriorated by 50
percent
and with no change in what they were
eating so
um so it's highly variable right so
that's theoretically the answer on a
practical level
i would say the answer is this right if
it comes in a package
you're probably better off not eating it
right
um if your ancestors couldn't have eaten
this
even 200 years ago it's probably not
worth eating
so if you just followed that advice
think about how many things you'd
eliminate from your diet
right if you just took packaged foods
away right from your diet
and again notice i'm agnostic you want
to be a vegan knock yourself out you
want to be the paleo man of the century
go for it i don't give a [ __ ] okay like
i couldn't care less
right but if you can largely adhere to
those principles
you're kind of going to be fine do you
want you know you're going to get
70 percent of the way there you want to
get 80 90 100 of the way there yeah well
then there's no simple answer
now at that point you got to dial in and
you got to go full immersion into
how do you tweak to your biochemistry
how much protein
what's the timing of the meals when do
we fast i mean all of the stuff that
uh is is my world and maybe soon to be
your world
uh that that's um that's the that's the
stuff for which you cannot provide you
know systemic advice
but at the at the societal level or at
the just the most basic level
yeah i mean think about that advice like
you don't you don't eat sugar anymore
you won't eat refined carbohydrates
anymore you're not going to eat
you know processed crappy foods anymore
what are you going to eat you're going
to eat fruits you're going to eat
vegetables you're going to eat meat
you're going to eat grain you know what
kind of grains are you gonna eat well
you know you're you know you're not
gonna really eat these sort of refined
crappy grains that people eat you're
gonna
you know you're you're starches i'm
sorry not grains your starches are
probably gonna be in the form of
potatoes and rice
so again a lot of you know again i just
i sort of
i think the reason i don't talk about
nutrition anymore is i don't find it to
be an intellectually honest
discussion anymore i find it to be just
a discussion of dogma right so if you're
a low-carb camp you're a low-carb camp
if you're in the
you know whatever the vegan camp you're
in the vegan camp like there's that you
can't even have a discussion about this
stuff
and at least not with most people yeah
so i just
you know you ever read the book called
diet cults
i know so does it get into this
that's the whole book really so
interesting fun to read
so good all right we'll have to check
that out